[Music]
this morning the new battles at the
border over the most dangerous narcotic
law enforcement has ever seen and how
cartels are getting drugs across we told
you recently about how the fentanyl
problem in the United States has gone
from bad to worse as we spend time on
the streets of Maine plus inside a
Maximum Security Prison now a different
trip to the busiest border crossing in
the world
[Music]
where are you going today
at the San Ysidro Port of Entry in
between San Diego and Tijuana more than
65
000 Vehicles cross every day what are we
passing through now so this is a piece
of what we call our non-intrusive
inspection technology so this enables us
to scan
as a driver drives to his or her vehicle
through or looking for packages
concealed within that vehicle Port
director Marisa Marin says by now 60
percent of all the fentanyl seized in
the United States is found at border
crossings in Southern California when
did fentanyl start becoming a big deal
here so we first saw fentanyl in 2008
but really we've seen a Skyrocket and
Fentanyl since fiscal year 2019. you'll
see what the officer is doing he's using
what we call a fiber optic scope and so
that has a camera at the end and it
enables him to look in the gas tank they
store the packages in gas tanks
absolutely and so we've seen it in
different ways there could be packages
floating in the gas tank or they could
build a separate compartment within the
gas tank so that there's both gas and
space for the narcotics and the package
is a fentanyl we're talking about coming
in are typically like
yay big yeah I'd say you know the size
maybe of a brick could be a couple
hundred thousand dollars worth of
Fentanyl
the seats
in the seat so I'm gonna push on the
seat
and make sure that it feels right
the CBP officers who run the vehicle
inspections search for signs of hidden
drugs in places most would never think
to look
sometimes they can create a compartment
right here and I don't see any new
screws or anything there's no time frame
over here it's all dirty I mean it
hasn't been touched another track you
put your feet over here yeah and tap it
this way to hear the vibration on the
other side
it's a lot of stuff to search yeah
assisted by trained canines they can
search thousands of vehicles a day it's
a constant cat and mouse game here
they're trying to get better at what
they're doing and you're trying to and
we're trying to counter those efforts
efforts which include not just where
they hide the drugs
but also who they use to carry them
right now we're seeing a trend in Miners
and young adolescents who come from less
economic means being targeted in high
schools in junior highs and these
smuggling organizations are offering
them for them what seems is a lot of
money 500 a thousand dollars and tell
them to put this in your pocket put this
in your backpack and cross the border
with it how long is that Trend been
going on for it's increased in the last
few months with the trend for for
juveniles smuggling across our ports of
Entry I think that the smuggling
organizations are very agile then
they're the far more elaborate efforts
we're here just a stone's throw from the
border you can see part of a border wall
just across that parking lot across this
street there's a warehouse Building
looks like hundreds of other Warehouse
buildings along the U.S Mexico border
here in San Diego but last May
authorities found underneath that
building six stories underground a
tunnel that was 1700 feet long
connecting the two countries that was
used for drug smuggling that tunnel had
electricity and small train tracks and
authorities have no idea how long it was
in operation who was running it and how
many others like it maybe left it's
getting worse it continues to grow what
do you need to help so for us at CBP
it's layered enforcement it's the
ability to really focus technology layer
our enforcement efforts and as we look
at trends
for smuggling techniques fentanyl
um
kids a very small portion can go a long
way and it doesn't have to be a huge
amount to be able to make an impact to
our community
how many of these vehicles would you
have to search to stop all the drugs
from coming in the ability to find every
single piece of fentanyl that's smuggled
into the United States quite frankly
doesn't exist but it's really the effort
to leverage both technology officer
instincts training and intelligence to
really really deter some of the solicit
activity
new CBP numbers out just last week about
the number of Narcotics being seized in
the last period marijuana down cocaine
down heroin down meth down fentanyl up
wow and it's being it's being laced in
all of these drugs as well so it remains
so deadly and so dangerous is it taking
over were these other drugs are sort of
losing some popularity or I mean people
are taking it by itself and then it's
being laced as well yeah which is why I
mean somebody told us last year there's
no such thing as Rec they say there's no
such thing as recreational drug use
anymore because you never know never
know that's right and I think we all
sort Michelle and I at least in that
moment of who's who's smuggling it and
you hear about the kids and children for
five hundred a thousand dollars well I
know I know two people
um close to my family who lost their
lives because they smoked marijuana
laced with fentyl fentanyl young people
it's terrible in their 20s awful great
reporting that you've been doing on the
Jeff though really great